myriam fehmiu bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation au
plaisir d'être là mais on a l'habitude
de vous voir derrière le micro
interviewant les autres cette
journaliste à radio canada ouais oui
mais aujourd'hui vous êtes de l'autre
côté du micro exactement d'animatrice
symphonie cause c'est maintenant moi qui
dois faire la promotion d'un événement
fait j'en accepte pour un des événements
où je supporte parole
j'ai accepté celui de deux nuits
d'afrique parce que
c'est un événement qui me tient vraiment
à coeur personnellement lors des
premières années de nuits d'afrique je
venais d'arriver à montréal après avoir
grandi dans un petit village à la
campagne au québec en mauricie
quand je suis arrivé à montréal ça les
premières années de nuits d'afrique
et puis mes parents qui nous ont
toujours baigné dans la musique que
felipe - on a découvert montréal à
travers des festivals et notamment
travers nuits d'afrique poussent la
musique africaine a toujours beaucoup
tourné chez nous reste instinct je suis
pas une porte parole un peu émotive oui
exactement qui travaille aussi à issy
musée musique ensemble on collaborent
ensemble on n'a jamais une émission à
tous les deux ensemble ça viendra
peut-être laissé dernier mais ouais si
l'on sait que les portes des gérants
avec beaucoup de plaisir avec
délectation comme d'habitude alors mis
en tant qu'ambassadrice de la 33e
édition du festival nuits d'afrique
c'est quoi les messages les principaux
messages que vous allez diffusé à cette
occasion un mais moi ce que je remarque
est une des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai
accepté d'être porte parole c'est que je
trouve que le festival c'est vraiment
très bien renouveler c'est à dire que on
garde une belle part aux musiques
traditionnelles africaines notamment
salif keita va être là qui vient du main
exactement 10 ans 50 ans de son ultime
album
en plus il a dit que cette salle et son
dernier album viennent nous présenter
montréal il y à des soirées de musique
mandingue
la musique traditionnelle est encore
très présent mais il y aussi des jeunes
des jeunes rappeurs de la guinée
notamment du mali de la côte d'ivoire de
la colombie qui viennent aussi avec
leurs sont beaucoup plus moderne très
2019 donc tout ça je trouve que ça se
côtoient bien des fois quand on mélange
de générations mais il peut y avoir des
incompréhensions et l'enfant est un
espèce de pont génération
c'est une musique ou en fait c'étaient
des groupes qui se complète assez bien
oui exactement
alors il ya donc le thème de l'inclusion
dit j'ai bien compris parce qu'on a de
musique qui viennent de partout ailleurs
dans le monde de l'amérique latine des
antilles aussi oui et plusieurs
personnes qui trouve ça étrange de voir
des groupes de la colombie qui sont
programmés au festival
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que on
s'est donné à la programmation unis une
ligne directrice a threat de d'entendre
les musiques qui découle de la musique
africaine
puis on sait très bien que la colombie a
des liens très forts avec le mans
barisis lentilles la jamaïque les
caraïbes
donc on aura l'occasion d'entendre tous
ces sons là je pensais systema solar
notamment de la colombie junkie et une
jamaïcaine qui représente le trouve
clairement le renouveau de la musique
reggae est à dire une femme et elle a
même des nouvelles sonorités où c'est ce
style là donc voilà on se rend compte
que le festival déroule également son
tapis rouge aux femmes dans les oui
clairement clairement en fait c'est pas
c'est même pas difficile de faire une
série spéciale avec les voix des femmes
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup de grand
talent qui
vraiment font plus que leur place là
ouvre la voie clairement au palmarès
avec la musique qu'elles font et puis
donc si ça cette année c'est la deuxième
année si je ne tombe pas oui les voies
du monde et qui ont été réservés aux
femmes
on va notamment ils entendent gélita pas
jelly tapas qui est la révélation du
canada et donc voilà cc oui c'est une
façon de l'ess de faire de la place aux
femmes mais en même temps j'aime pas
trop utiliser cette expression laquelle
sont déjà le sont déjà là elles prennent
véritablement la place qu'il exhale
alors myriam on n'a pas parlé du lieu
même du déroulement de ce festival
ouais c'est où précisément dans les rues
et dans les salles de montréal il ya il
ya des salles mythiques à montréal comme
le bal à tous qui de pagès j'en ai même
pas dit elle avait plusieurs décennies
accueil avant même que ce soit à la mode
la ouvrait ses portes aux plus grands
artistes de musiques du monde de
l'afrique aux antilles et tranquillement
avec les années qui ont passé le
spectacle a grandi s'est déplacé sur la
rue saint-laurent et puis là-bas est au
quartier des spectacles
donc toutes les activités gratuites aux
que ce soit les spectacles ou que ça
soit par exemple les restaurants ciel
ouvert la boutique les jeux pour enfants
tout ça se passe sur le parterre du
quartier des spectacles
et puis dans bon nombre de salles je
pense au club soda à la tulipe est bien
là tout bien évidemment je crois que
quelques spectacles om telus aussi dans
le fond ce festival là c'est pas que des
sonorités il ya de la bouffe aussi de la
bouffe afrique
c'est un effet les préférées c'est pas
souvent on a l'occasion de manger
hooley yassa montréal qui vous préparez
donc moi c'est moi depuis quand la
demande exactement le vrai piquant pour
ceux qui connaissent et puis ben non
homogène j'adore ce volet là parce qu'il
ya vraiment tout la deuxième fin de
semaine c'est vraiment le volet de rue
avec énormément d'activités gratuites
pour la famille et puis moi je vais
animer aussi deux dj set pendant ce
dernier week end là c'est à dire à 21h
le 19 et le 20 des dj que j'aime
beaucoup montana que fait non mixtes
pour l'émission rapeau phonique jeanine
qui est une émission de hip hop
francophone
donc elle elle va mixer pendant 40
minutes entre les deux gros spectacle de
la soirée
question d'ambiance est un peu le
quartier et le lendemain c'est king
habile le 20 juillet j'avais fait ça il
ya deux ans c'était chaud mais oui je
vous invite ce secteur
alors dites moi mais rien c'est dans les
rues donc c'est gratuit il n'y a pas de
raison que les gens manquent que c'est
ça c'est exactement ce que je me dis oui
à des spectacles qui sont payants quand
on pense à des salif keita ou des dj
force 3 qui est un groupe hyper connue
en afrique de l'ouest
oui il ya des prix d'entrée pour les
salles les spectacles en salle
fuld très haut calibre qui sont aussi
dans les rues avant de se dire ah bon
c'est programmé dans la rue là c'est les
plus gros qui commence non non il ya
vraiment une grosse grosse programmation
aller chercher le dépliant les sur le
site web là vous allez voir si je passe
à travers la liste on va y passer la
journée mais énormément de spectacles de
qualité aussi gratuite à feu est ce
qu'il ya une programmation sur
l'esplanade de radio-canada ici non pas
que je sache non pas qu'elle change
ok super dans tous les cas en résumé un
message pour le public mais venez là on
n'a pas une têtière chouette jusqu'à
maintenant mais
vous souhaitez le vase est il exactement
la saison mineurs autour du soleil
9 au 21 juillet habituellement il fait
chaud là il n'y a pas de raison de ne
pas venir nous rencontrer pis mais moi
je vais y être pas mal je vais aller
même vraiment prendre des bains de foule
allait jaser avec les gens je vais aller
voir plein air chaud donc on a
l'occasion de se croiser alors c'était
un myriam fehmiu qui est donc la porte
parole du festival nuits d'afrique qui
est rendu à sa 33e édition
meriane je vous remercie infiniment
quelqu'un une fois merci les et
partageur va